aren't a busy news night we begin with a
Fox News Alert the Department of Justice
has now paved the way for former Deputy
FBI director Andrew McCabe to possibly
be indicted tonight Fox News has learned
federal prosecutors recommended moving
forward with criminal charges against
McCabe after his last-minute appeal was
officially rejected McCabe was once the
second highest ranking member of the FBI
the interim director after super patriot
Jim Comey was fired and McCabe was also
Jim Comey's right-hand man and he was
trusted to oversee some of the highest
profile cases in the bureau and in the
country but in 2018 Andrew McCabe was
fired
why for lying and for leaking the DOJ
inspector general he issued a seething
rebuke of the fire deputy director and
he was determined that he lacked candor
that's what was determined he in other
words he didn't tell the truth quote
then Deputy Director Andrew McCabe quote
lack candor including under oath on
multiple occasions in connection with
describing his role in connection with a
disclosure to The Wall Street Journal
the IG also accused McCabe of unlawfully
leaking sensitive government information
to the press and then blaming the leaks
on other people including quote McCabe
violated the FBI's and the department's
media policy and constituted misconduct
as you can see McCabe's characters
anything but sterling perfect guy to
hire a fake new CNN he also played a
vital role in the FISA fraud against
Carter page approving warrants and the
approval of those warrants that relied
on the dirty steal dossier McCabe
infamous saying oh yeah no FISA warrant
told the house in telecom itty no
surveillance warrant would have been
sought from the FISA Court without the
Steele dossier information which later
the FBI I found out was yeah none of it
was true over 90 percent they proved
false
now mccabe and his boss Jim Comey they
had been warned by multiple government
agencies by many high-ranking officials
they were also warned about using that
dossier by at least one foreign
government that Steele so-called
intelligence was unreliable not Vera
Russian disinformation to quote the New
York Times likely from the beginning
bought and paid for by Hillary hmm
that's true if the New York Times is
Right likely Russian disinformation from
the beginning that would mean Russia and
Putin wanted Hillary to win now we now
know not only was it unverifiable that's
all an author testified under oath that
he has no idea of any of the contents of
true when the FBI did finally get around
to trying to verify it they concluded
yeah we can't find anything true here
they were able to prove untrue over 90
percent of it yet call me signed the
warrant and subsequent renewals three
warrants of the four he signed saying it
was true and accurate at the top of a
FISA warrant it says verified that makes
this premeditated fraud on a FISA Court
they were warned about steel that
Hillary paid for it and it wasn't
verified but none of that seemed to
matter McCabe like his boss Comey they
hated Donald Trump he Hills John Solomon
reported that according to the former
FBI general counsel James Baker McCabe
was quote dead serious about the idea
surreptitiously recording the 45th
President of the United States and using
the evidence to make the case that Trump
should be removed from office Oh
COO McCabe even said on 60 minutes rod
Rosen Stein was serious about the wire
and others serious about invoking the
25th amendment my sources telling me in
the cave could in fact face criminal
charges I'd assume this means that a
grand jury will be convened 10 days 7 10
14 days we'll wait and see I want to be
very clear though
now what Andrew McCabe to know this just
like remember oh yeah that lawyer for
stormy Daniels I gave him the benefit of
the doubt we live in a country where
accusations against anybody even from
the DOJ Inspector General and former
colleagues the FBI yeah they're
incredibly damning aren't they but
everybody deserves the presumption of
innocence innocent until proven guilty
in a court of law and by the way I will
not deviate from that it looks bad looks
like Andrew McCabe is gonna face justice
very soon now no one has to wonder if
maybe he's feeling differently tonight
about his treatment in Colby's treatment
of a 33-year veteran named general Flynn